le site l'outsider a mené une enquête
avec sos racisme à propos de plusieurs
agences immobilières alors je le dis
parce que tout le monde a dit que ça
concernait que stéphane plaza les
annonces de ses vols bata ça concerne
toutes les agences immobilières donc le
post stéphane plaza et sonneries plein
et violée oui mais voilà c'est ça
concerne tout le monde à journaliste
s'est fait passer pour un propriétaire
qui veut louer son appartement avec des
critères raciaux prédéfinis les
résultats de cette agence sont
surprenants car on y apprend que
plusieurs agences favoriserait la
discrimination raciale de ses locataires
regardez c'est un coup dur pour stéphane
plaza et son réseau d'agencés
immobilières composé de 428 franchisés à
travers la france alors que tout semble
sourire à l'agent immobilier le plus
célèbre de france une polémique vient
entacher le tableau presque parfait
c'est une enquête menée par sos racisme
sur la discrimination raciale à la
location qui est à l'origine de cette
polémique
si elle a été menée sur plusieurs
réseaux tels que foncia la forêt ou
encore orpi les agences de stéphane
plaza font également parler d'elle une
enquête qui révèle une triste réalité
globale un profil asiatiques à 15 % de
chances en moins d'avoir allongement
qu'une personne d'origine française
ancienne une personne d'origine
maghrébine à 28 % de chances en moins et
une personnes d'afrique subsaharienne à
38 % de chances en moins les agents
stéphane plaza ont également été épinglé
suite à l'enregistrement d'un agent de
la firme qui a dérapé enregistré par
téléphone
c'est par le jeu et musique si je veux
préféré par la communauté européenne
vous en tiendra compte même si ce n'est
pas écrit en plein tournage l'animateur
de m6 a tenu à réagir à cette polémique
je ne peux pas parler de choses que je
n'ai pas encore vu personnellement on
m'a parlé de choses je vais faire le
nécessaire et déjà regarder avant il
faut voir les choses avant de dire si
c'est réel déjà j'ai prouvé que je suis
à l'encontre de toutes ces valeurs qui
sont abordés je suis le français de
toutes les couleurs espérons que
stéphane plaza trouve une solution
contre les inégalités au logement
alors je vous le dis le sujet je trouve
je trouve pas bon du tout parce que ça
c'est ont fait vraiment arrêté sur
stéphane bad alors qu il plaint d'
agences immobilières et stéphane plaza
je le dis voilà je dis pas ça parce que
c'est mon pote il peut pas être derrière
toutes les agences
forcément il y a plein d'argent ce voilà
alors qu'ils aient des problèmes en tout
cas au niveau des propriétaires qui
demande à oui mais qui ont des exilés
qui ont des exigences qui sont ces
convergences aux grenouilles voilà mes
stéphane plaza il peut pas que derrière
tous les téléphones et dire aux gars tu
peux pas prendre ce mec là après c'est
vrai que peut-être les agences
immobilières devrait dire voilà si vous
avez de tel de telles demandes
eh ben on vous prend prochaine nous
voilà oui j moi j'ai trouvé que la
réaction de stéphane crozat était très
bonne
il ne nie pas le problème qui est réel
dans l'ensemble des agences immobilières
effectivement pas du tout que dans les
siennes mais il dit je vais regarder et
s'il ya quelque chose je vais agir
éventuellement je vais sanctionnés il se
précipite pas mais il nie pas le
problème
c'est vraiment bien c'est un chef
d'entreprise responsable je trouve guy
me mohamed ce qui est dramatique c'est
qu'on porte la polémique sur stéphane
plaza alors et c'est ça c'est l'ensemble
les agences immobilières actuellement
tout ça tout ça pour faire du buzz et
pas de parler de stéphane plaza le
problème n'est pas stéphane plaza c'est
ses agents immobiliers qui font la
discrimination six ont assisté aux
mondiaux on découvre ça en france mais
ça on sait très bien ce que lorsqu'on
est noir ou arabe c'est plus difficile
d'avoir un job que à 2 cv est exactement
identique est pas forcément le mohammed
sera moins favorisés que l'autre c'est
factuel et demain le jour où ces noirs
et les arabes décideront de faire déjà
jonché des agences immobilières
communautaire mourir mais regardez vous
replier sur nous-mêmes mais c'est normal
on vous exclut donc appartement où on
est exclu
forcément eh ben on reste entre soi et
donc je trouve lamentable ça qu'on se
focalise sur stéphane plaza mais il faut
que la société évolue même si on n'est
pas fous de ce reportage pour savoir
alors je vous dis
l'enquète nous apprend aussi que plus de
53 % des agences testés acceptent de
pratiquer la discrimination raciale et
de sélectionner en toute discrétion les
dossiers des candidats au trophée norris
cette pratique est pourtant condamné à
trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé
voilà donc il ya une chose qui est
encore pire parce que la situation des
extraterrestres est encore beaucoup plus
alors là c'est vrai que la nature est
vrai qu'on y skie vraiment des gens qui
sont qui se retrouve vraiment dans la
merde à cause de ça via les gens des
propriétaires qui font des demandes
complètement saugrenue qui vraiment je
vous dis ça c'est complètement nul de
faire ça mais c'est pas de la faute de
stéphane plaza
malheureusement voilà bien dit s'il peut
pas tout faire